قال وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يوقلنت ان تل
ابيب شكرت الاداره الامريكيه على ما سماه
دعمها غير المشروط للعمليه العسكريه التي
نفذها جيش الاحتلال في جنين مؤخرا كان ذاك
خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما
هي حقيقه
المشروب الذي قدمته اداره بايدن لعمليه
قوات الاحتلال العسكريه الاخيره في جنين
والى اي حد يمكن ان تشكل عمليه جنين مدخلا
لمقاربه مختلفه تتخذها اداره بايدن وما هي
الانعكاسات المحتمله على دور واشنطن كراع
لعمليه السلام
اعتقد ان هناك
نوع من التلاعب بالكلمات في هذا المجال
فقد تعلق الامر بتعريف الدعم انا الولايات
المتحده كانت وما ستستمر في الدعم دوله
اسرائيل بعدد طرق دعم مالي والدعم اقتصادي
ودعم اجتماعي اداره بايدن عليها ان تكون
حذره جدا ازاعه ما يحصل في جنين وما يحصل
في عمليه التصعيد في الظفر الغربيه على يد
اداره نتنياهو وبالتالي ثمه جزئين في هذا
اولا يجب
نفصل الدعم المالي المستمر للتقدمه
الولايات المتحده عن طريق الكونجرس ما
الذي يحصل بشكل محدد في ما بعد مرحله
ماساه جنين الموقف المعلن الامريكي الرسمي
والبريطاني ايضا كان
ما تقوم به اسرائيل من جريمه حرب في جنين
عمليه دفاع عن النفس تهجير 4000 انسان
بالقوه المسلحه من منازلهم ليس سوى جريمه
حرب قتل اربع اطفال بالاضافه الى الشهداء
الاخرين ليس سوى جريمه حرب هناك تواضع مع
استمرار الاحتلال تواطئ مع نظام الاطرتيد
العنصري وهناك تواطئ مع حقيقه انه حكومه
استعماريه استيطانيه فيها فاشيين تقوم
بتحطيم اي امكانيه لوجود دوله فلسطينيه
اداره بايدن هذا الاسبوع انا رايت ارى
انها لم تكن شديده او عدوانيه كما ينبغي
فيما يتعلق بالتواصل وعدم الموافق على مثل
هذا النوع من السلوك والماسات التي حصلت
اعتقد ان الرئيس الوزراء نتنياهو السيد
اتفعل بالتصعيد الى حد بعيد جدا وهذا امر
الولايات المتحده بشكل خاص دائره وحتى
عندما كان نائبا للرئيس وقبل ذلك عندما
كان هو مطلع جدا على ما يقوم به الضجه من
نتنياهو
وموقفه اليمين المتطرف لو ارادت الولايات
المتحده لو ارادت تستطيع ان تجبر اسرائيل
في عشر دقائق على الاقل على وقف الاستيطان
الذي تدينه وتقول انه يدمر امكانيه قيام
دوله فلسطينيه مستقله دائره على رايي الذي
امامها ايام واسابيع صعبه جدا بل واشهر
صعبه جدا عليهم اثناء ان يتاكدوا من
الامور لا تخرج عن السيطره
الكاس الاول ان هناك فقدان كامل للثقه ليس
فقط بالولايات المتحده بل بالمجتمع الدولي
ككل تعميق شعورهم بانه لا حل سوى المقاومه
والكفاح المقارنه بين موقف الولايات
المتحده في اوكرانيا والغرب عموما وبينما
يجري في فلسطين لماذا اعطوهم الاسلحه
واعطوهم المدرعات والطائرات ومليارات
الدولارات ليحاربوا روسيا وفرضوا 11 الف
عقوبه على روسيا في غضون شهرين ولا عقوبه
واحده على اسرائيل واعتقد الولايات
المتحده واداره بايدن بشكل خاص تجد نفسها
في موقف انه علينا ان نخفف الامور ونتاكد
بان الاعمال العوف هذه لن تزداد اكثر دوله
في العالم تستطيع ان تضغط على اسرائيل هي
الولايات المتحده ام الولايات المتحده
تقدم لاسرائيل كل الاسلحه الولايات
المتحده تعطي اسرائيل ثلاث مليارات دولار
سنويا مساعدات عسكريه الولايات المتحده
تسمح بجمع تبرع ات لاسرائيل لا تقل عن 12
مليار دولار سنويا الولايات المتحده هي
التي تمنع اتخاذ اي قرار في مجلس الامن ضد
الجرائم الاسرائيليه